et maintenant essayer d'en savoir un peu
plus sur le duo d du jour avec l'ami
thomas l'hérault qui est avec nous tu ne
le disais tout à l'heure tu es en
terminale es au lycée jean marc boivin
c'est ça c'est ça à chevigny saint
sauveur travaille très bien tu souffres
desquels handicap toi thomas d'un
handicap moteur
en fait je suis très grands prématurés
et quand je suis venu au monde
en fait il ya une zone de 10 à une zone
du cerveau
l'oxygénation s'est pas fait et les
neurones moteurs n'ont pas pu pas pu
fonctionner correctement
donc voilà je précise parce que vous
n'avez pas vu la la mise en place entre
guillemets de thomas mais tu te déplaces
au quotidien photo line dont un thomas
voilà était accepté d'être avec nous sur
ce siège pour participer à l'émission tu
aurais pu tout à fait rester dans son
fauteuil roulant mais tu t'es dit c'est
plus confortable
donc voila tu vas passer un petit bout
de temps avec nous parce que c'est ta
journée en fait c'est toi qui a choisi
de venir faire ce stage en l'occurrence
c'est à france télévisions il il ya
beaucoup de gens comme toi qui souffre
de deux handicaps qui sont avec nous sur
toutes les chaînes du groupe france
télévisions aujourd'hui toi tu voudrais
faire quoi je voudrais je voudrais bien
devenir réalisateur l'art de films de
films carrément super c'est que la ja
gens qui est aux manettes qui est un
technicien avec nous qu'ils réalisent
qui fait plein de petites choses acquis
et boutons et que son plan régis là tu
vois donc tout à l'heure tu ira les voir
là tu vois l'autre côté un vice a
comment on bat c au début je me suis dit
ça va être très très intimidant non
quand on y est ça va finalement n'est
pas si méchant que ça on est comme dans
la vraie vie oui puis tu sais moi je dis
souvent il n'y a pas de mauvaises
interio n'a que des mauvaises il n'y a
pas de nos interviews de mauvaise
l'interview voilà tu es moi j'arrive à
me i'm a mélangé les crayons ton avenir
professionnel tu le vois vraiment dans
le cinéma
j'aimerais mais c'est pour ça que j'ai
accepté de faire ce stage aussi c'est
pour voir d'autres opportunités de voir
comment ça se passe à la télévision par
exemple et tout mais c'est vrai que le
cinéma c'est toujours quelque chose qui
m'a passionné
donc j'aimerais m'orienter là dessus
mais si jamais j'ai d'autres
opportunités et les saisir et tu as
raison
quel genre de cinéma tu es un peu près
tous les styles
j'ai pas vraiment de style louis de
style que je préfère où j'aime les
regarder tous les genres de signer des
cinémas ya pas j'ai pas de préférence et
tu attends quoi de cette journée
précisément thomas ou au delà des
rencontres de voir un peu l'envers du
décor d' découvert certaines choses
maintenant de savoir comment
parce que quand on quand on regarde là
quand on regarde les programmes à la
télé on sait pas forcément
l'organisation qui a derrière et
j'aimerais j'aimerais approfondir après
approfondir sa savoir comment comment ça
se passe et voilà alors tu es arrivé on
va pas le cacher un petit peu au dernier
moment
quinze minutes avant d'en encore pas vu
grand chose néanmoins de ce que tu as vu
qu'est ce qui t'a le plus plu qu'est ce
qui t'a le plus dérangé aussi 1,6 et
surtout avant de avant d'arriver dans
sur le plateau de l'émission c'est
surtout de savoir que que les gens sont
là pour nous rassurer que c'est très
très conviviale il ya ton binôme qui est
planqué la basse et corinne coco qui
nous assiste dans l'émission je sais pas
si on peut la voir discrètement elle
aime pas qu on la montre à la caméra
mais je pense qu'elle peut faire un
petit effort voilà faire un petit plan
sur sur corinne qui sera tendue au parce
que c'est ça le duo dire c'est une
personne de l'entreprise qui accompagne
vers l'occurrence e thomas ton quotidien
aux six lycées on va pas se le cacher tu
fais quoi
au lycée je suis en terminale es ouais
et g j'ai eu un parcours scolaire
aménagé avec le avec le lycée boivin
jean marc boivin chevigny saint sauveur
parce qu'il avait une classe pour les
pour les sportifs de haut niveau
on passe notre première terminale en
trois ans pour étaler les cours sur les
horaires d'entraînement des sportifs de
haut niveau
ils ont essayé ils ont accepté nous mène
dans cette classe pour que les cours
soient soit étalée pour que j'ai plus de
temps pour pour faire mes soins et c est
ce que ça veut dire que tu as fait aussi
un petit peu de sport j'ai fait du j'ai
eu des cours de handisport pendant mes
années lycée j'ai fait du hand et basket
du durant dossier ouais et toutes sortes
de sports et cette année je me suis
inscrit
de ma propre initiative à la natation
parce que les cours de sport se sont
sont terminées avec le l'obtention du
bac de sport donc j'ai voulu continuer à
bien ces super en tout cas c'est pour
bientôt là le bac
oui as incessamment sous peu le sens
comment si je connaisse bien sado real a
déjà passé le bac français tous et ouais
les notes les notes arrêté ouais 11
alors aller et vous allez créer c'est
bien ça c'est mieux que françois saint
françois oui largement mieux largement
mieux puis largement mieux que moi
bon c'est très bien tu restes avec nous
on va encore en parler un tout petit peu
de ce duo d avec cette participation
active à cette journée donc n'hésite pas
n'hésite pas si je dis une bêtise si
françois t'embête si tu veux donner
quelque chose à estelle tu en profites
tu sais ta journée le principe c'est
quoi le duo d je le rappelle c'est une
entreprise en l'occurrence c'est france
télévisions qui accueille aujourd'hui
une personne en situation de handicap en
duo avec un professionnel volontaires
seco coq est planqué dans les coulisses
la découverte du métier participation
active immersion en entreprise c'est une
vraie opportunité pour toi donc il faut
la saisir
d'accord je compte bien passé là bas et
à intérêts intérêts n'hésite pas tout
cas ça va nous permettre de changer de
regard ensemble et de dépasser nos
préjugés face à tous les handicaps tient
à la propos direction la nièvre avec
l'exemple du gauche hugo pour découvrir
là aussi une insertion réussie regarder
les gestes sont appliquées hugo est
concentrée depuis trois semaines le
jeune homme est en stage dans ce
restaurant collectif
à 21 ans il est atteint d'une forme
d'autisme
ici il a trouvé un cadre qui lui
convient
bien cuisiner car le service nettoyaient
la cuisine par tous et dessert entrée
plat titulaire d'un c ap cuisine il
recherchait une expérience concrète
continuer à se former dans un
environnement professionnel
là tu as fait en 3 concis d'affaires en
branchant première semaine de trois
jours ou quatre jours je connaissais
déjà
un peu pas mal de choses par une équipe
avec lui demander rapidement hugo à
trouver sa place au milieu des autres
salariés
un défi aussi pour le restaurant il n'y
a pas de traitement on va dire de faveur
voilà maintenant il a pris ses marques
on est en train de deux voilà on voit
tout de suite ils se sont beaucoup plus
à l'aise c'est là aussi
où il faut être vigilant parce que et ça
je pense que c'est voilà des signes par
rapport à l'autisme ou après il ya un
comportement de plus en plus familiers
l'iphone peu de rigueur grâce au
dispositif autisme à venir hugo évolue
dans un premier temps sous l'oeil
attentif de martin un accompagnement au
quotidien pour rassurer et lui permettre
de s'épanouir
notre présence dans un premier temps
permet de troubler de compenser un petit
peu ces difficultés il développe encore
ses compétences professionnelles
il est tout à fait en capacité de tenir
un poste en milieu ordinaire
après à nous de présenter aux employeurs
les étrilles existants pour pouvoir
permettre une insertion
si le stage est un succès hugo espère
qui lui permettra de convaincre de
nouveaux employeurs décrocher un contrat
et vivre de son métier comme n'importe
quel autre salarié
un bel exemple de vivre ensemble pour
hugo 15 21 ans 10 mois thomas si dans
l'absolu j'avais une baguette magique
comme ça qu'est ce que tu voudrais que
je fasse pour s'insérer dans le monde du
travail à me donner un travail sur tout
et est stable et que je puisse vivre il
de ce travail avec en étant le plus
autonome possible en tout cas profite de
cette journée un set à journée je le
redis n'hésite pas je disais tout à
l'heure 20 ans c'est l'âge de tous les
possibles
nous c'était il ya très longtemps
françois intense
[Rires]